let's go to the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
listened for your area code first why
don't we start off with a call from
Skype today the Skype calls can be good
or bad but we don't usually start with
them let's start there who's the caller
from Skype my on that's you Oh actually
I'm calling from Google Hangouts oh I
apologize all right shows up ok on
reason um my name is miles I live in
Arizona I'm ok so I have some questions
about the rush investigation and well a
I guess general question it has to do it
so I I'm a believer in it I'm not like a
denier but I I'm just wondering do you
think Robert Moeller knows something we
don't know I hope so relief oh my
goodness miles if we know everything
Robert Mulder knows we're screwed right
I mean it's like it but number one it
would be like why would we know
everything that the chief investigator
knows that would be really concerning
and it would also mean there might not
be much there so if whit miles if we
know you're scaring me buddy if we know
everything robert muller knows we're
screwed
yeah I mean it's just believe me I'm not
a denier it just seems like you know
like the I don't know it just seems like
Rob remote and also um there was a hill
report that um molar said Trump wasn't a
target and again I'm not a denier of the
rush investigation I'm just wondering
what does that mean to you if if when
Robert Muller's lawyers say to Trump's
lawyers that Trump is not a criminal
target at this point like what what does
that mean could mean a couple things
could mean genuinely that Trump is not
even suspected of maybe having done
anything criminal right like that's one
interpretation another could be that
robert muller is sort of building the
case like a pyramid and that he just
seemed hasn't even gotten yet to
starting to think about what crimes
Donald Trump may may have committed it
also just may mean it might be a legal
statement like as of right now Trump is
not formally a target of the
investigation but he is a person of
suspicion I saw that report and
we could guess but I don't really know
miles exactly what it what it means yeah
uh one last Oh what shoe wait a minute I
lost one hang on I'm trying to think for
a moment miles of the two questions you
asked were good I say we leave it there
I really do appreciate the call and
miles from Google Hangouts calling in
very very exciting